now you had lunch with him on Thursday
last week when he was to find out later
that day I think the about these
allegations when you saw him clearly
didn't know anything about them I mean
how was he
what he just got a very early train back
from Edinburgh I think he said it was 4
45 something like that into King's cross
because he'd been up for the BBC
reporting on the Scottish Crown Jewel
ceremy with the King uh I I think he'd
gone back home he'd change he's wearing
a wearing a sweater in the Woolsey which
is a sort of fashionable restaurant in
in Piccadilly in in central London and
he was in he was in high I could High
Spirits I thought I'm a very quite
gossipy about you know about Royal
protocol and so on uh certainly not with
a man with a tremendous Cloud Dark Cloud
hanging over him no but and then later
as you say his world
fell apart what did you make of the way
it came out in the sun I mean it's your
sister paper but what did was it
legitimate journalism do you think
I really can't speak to those editorial
decisions you only have journalists on
them on papers and news organizations
and the BBC uh make editorial decisions
uh all all the time and they I know they
wouldn't have gone with with this story
unless they were convinced that it was
uh in the public interest and and true
um but you know personally speaking I
was incredibly shocked by it it uh flew
against everything I thought I knew
about the man he could try and pride
yourself as a professional interviewer
that you can get to the truth of people
or or quite near it I'd interviewed them
twice I'd had two long lunches with him
this was a man who talked about his
family an awful Lots broke her you know
very lovely of his wife and his his
children as they were setting off a
university in and into their careers who
asked about my family we even talked
about going for a walk later this summer
along the uh South uh Wells Coast which
he which he absolutely adores so there's
all terrible cognitive dissonance I
didn't didn't believe it partly because
I didn't want to believe it I mean it's
interesting in the way this was dealt
with by the BBC given that the
complaints were made
um several weeks earlier before this
family went to the sun because arguably
if the BBC had investigated properly it
could have perhaps been dealt with in a
very different way for you know
internally for Hugh Edwards
well I I you know I wish they had
um
made the inquiries a bit more speedily
and had talked to him about them and
then the family would never have gone to
the to the press as I as I understand it
um as for these allegations that were
made uh on news night last night about
um
uh inappropriate messaging from Hugh
Edwards to members younger members of
Staff in the BBC Newsroom I mean that
I'd have thought could well have been an
HR or human resources uh matter rather
than a matter for an investigation uh
but of course in in this context
we were starved journalism was starved
of information for several days and uh
journalism went out and and found out
what it could
I mean what's your personal view do you
think there's a way back for Hugh
Edwards Andrew
I'd love to think he would be behind
that desk again in a in a few weeks or
months or presenting the
election night uh I I somehow doubt it
what I really hope really hope is that
he will have a career in broadcasting
Beyond this that he will make continue
to make documentaries as The Marvelous
documentary maker and presenter
especially on programs like Wales
you know his homeland about which he
feels passionately and if not then there
may be a job in Academia his father was
a was an academic and a historian he
admired his father very much uh that
might be another Avenue for him to
pursue but he's got to get past well
what is clearly a a severe mental
breakdown at the moment yes and we on
that we wish him well clearly I mean
what about the way Andrew that the BBC's
reported this John sopel a former
colleague of Hughes says some of his
former colleagues need to look at
themselves for the way they've covered
it he said he says it's a complicated
private life not a criminal one
um I just wonder your thoughts on that
I was surprised uh last night that
Newsnight continued to investigate
um this really given the fact that we
know that he was in a hospital
his son uh said they wouldn't be
carrying any more stories it seemed to
have been decent haste but I can
understand it from the BBC's point of
view they have to if they go if they
zealously go after other other public
figures who committed some kind of
wrongdoing to be seen to be independent
they have to do this do the same with
their own it is it's a terribly Tangled
uh web here what I do think is that it
involves all-round vulnerable people a
vulnerable young person who had a drug
habit uh other other young people and
inexperienced people perhaps and a
disparity of power in The Newsroom if
those rumors are right those those
complaints are are founded but you can
be a very highly paid very famous a very
respected television presenter and be a
vulnerable person too and I think we
found out he for you is very vulnerable